hello
it's good to be here
my name
is hans kim
and it's december 25th 2021
the one and only christmas day
and i'm streaming i hope
uh usually sometimes there's two buttons
i have to press
but this time i only had to press one so
i'm kind of nervous that this isn't even
doing anything so i'll start recording
now that i know things are happening
i can actually get down into the
nitty-gritty of this
this uh
this broadcast
this is not my van i am broadcasting
live from a home in austin texas
the home of a man who is very very
uh esteemed and powerful
in the comedy community whose name i
probably shouldn't say
um
and uh
i i've been enjoying my time here it's
been a very lovely lovely home that i've
been able to house sit
and look after the dog
in
which is somewhere i guess i'm not doing
a very good job of looking after the dog
but
yeah this is my kitchen
this is the kitchen in the van
this is uh
no just kidding
um
what's the hit list look like this past
week
so first person i'm probably gonna
murder
is my good friend riley gilmore because
he flaked on katan seshes a couple times
last week
um
i don't understand nfts they just seem
like captchas
why don't you just invest in captures
um
uh
but honestly it's not riley gilmore's
fault because
i've been hanging out with
a little
[Music]
little man i mean i shouldn't say that
i've been hanging out with the big man
and big man on campus a lot
and it's kind of gotten in the way and
i've been hanging out with him until
like midnight one am
it's pretty crazy hanging out with the
big man because he's just
such a
huge star in a way that's unfathomable
to the normal human mind
uh we went to this place that we we go
to or he goes to or that i sometimes go
to that he sometimes goes to a lot of
different places
that we all go to sometimes but this one
place in particular
we were at this one time
and some guy comes up to him and is like
could i could we get a little
and then uh the guy the security guy had
to step in and it's like
damn i wish i could have enough money so
i could just get out of awkward
exchanges just be like
sidestep you your hose you hose
[Music]
hans how do you think red bar will react
to you calling joe a little man
i don't have a shotgun is han sleep
talking again this is how i talk man if
you need a blues clues host then you can
go
find a blues clues house
i'm not hanging with ari ari was here i
saw him and then he recorded the podcast
with joe
and
um
i mean i guess i do have a very slow way
of talking
uh
the big man he is uh very very big and
he gives me lots and lots of
favors
he treats his people well
and let's just say that i've been
opening for him
recently i think i'm allowed to say that
i'm just so nervous because i don't want
to say the wrong thing um but
merry christmas
for all the crips out there you know
holla at your boy
in the house 50210 or whatever
i'm in someone's kitchen because i'm
recording and i'm having fun and living
the life
this is hans came coming to you live
from someone's kitchen
i am not high my eyes are open i'm not
tired this is just how i talk welcome to
the podcast
is that what you want you want noises oh
i went to the mall the other day
the mall is so great i love them all
when i was at the mall i was very
emotional i was like
but then i got really angry because
there was a dude there who was
challenging me to a fight to sleep with
his girlfriend
oh i am a man and i will fight you i
said
and then we fought and i was victorious
victory surging through my body
testosterone this is what you guys want
this is what i think that uh
you guys would like
um
and then yo bro this chick she was so
[ __ ] hot dude she was she had like
nice tits and when i was sucking on her
tits she accidentally squirted on my
torso and then i was like oh gross dude
i got
jizz on my torso
and then i accidentally came and then
turns out i was a dude
um
yeah i mean
i'm having a great time
you the man hans the shoulders back and
balls out
uh
can you do an impression of a bland
white guy
okay hey guys so
i'm uh
i'm really nervous about how people want
to change things like just kind of want
everything to stay the same and i just
want to distract myself with
buying things and uh
concerts and going to restaurants and i
just don't understand why people just
want to change things all the time
things are so great for me why would you
want to change things
i mean don't you just want to feel
pleasure and comfort your whole life and
then die
aren't you just like cattle that's just
meant to feel
pleasurable emotions and safety for the
whole time and then you die isn't that
what we all want don't we not want to
actually do anything with our lives but
just be comfortable the whole time
i don't know why everyone is so angry
it's kind of getting me angry but in a
way that won't make anything different i
want to be angry in a way that will make
everything
the same
i'm so white
i'm so white
i'm white all the time
sometimes when i'm white
i accidentally put too much mayonnaise
on my sandwich which is fine cause it
makes it more white like me
i'm white all the time
i love whites
and the whites love me
i'm pretty white
as an asian man
asians are the closest to whiteness you
can get the good thing about being asian
is that we have the minority street cred
with the white person bank account it's
the best of both worlds
i love ufos i wish they were real i
don't know what a is uap unidentified
axe astrological
panda
[Music]
sex um
but uh yeah front butts are in for
christmas from boots you mean a fupa
um but i wish they were real but it's
just like why waste time thinking about
it it's like it's not going to manifest
because we think about it more and they
don't want to talk to us if they do
exist
so it's like hey let's not think about
it they don't want us to think about
them so let's just focus on ourselves
there's enough problems that we have to
fix and stuff
aerial phenomena undefined aerial
phenomenons
okay
uh ufos are great i wish they were real
i mean
we all want a man in the sky to help us
and fix all our
problems must get on the trt i would
love to inject some trt i'm not an
athlete i'm not getting dope tested
shoot me up give me all the best things
make my body the body of an
a greek god
[ __ ] me up dog i want it
uh why are we why are we acting like
doing steroids is a bad thing
i mean if you overdo it anything is bad
but uh something that will make you
stronger and more awesome yes please can
i get more of that inside my balls
i love
i love drugs and i think drugs are very
powerful and we should utilize it more
we don't because the purpose of society
isn't to
maximize the potential of each
individual but to make sure that we are
not going to change anything and [ __ ]
[ __ ] up for the people up top so
we are purposely made to be
useless and uh
not
really changing things and stuff i got a
new light
so
this now i'm really white
hey guys you guys want to play
pickleball
hey guys
you guys ever seen
django and chained i love that movie
i'm house sitting for somebody
so that's just what i uh i did
i'm just house sitting uh i move out
soonish and then i go to the other house
that i'm house sitting uh
where are you from originally i was born
in the city
in a city in the east coast near new
york city but not quite new york
um i don't want to say should i say
where i'm from because
uh
can't you steal my identity
uh if i tell you what city i'm from
rdk but
my social security number starts with a
10.
um
so yeah i mean jasmine i hope you're a
woman if you got to move into a van soon
i would recommend it
vans are the way to go um i've been
thinking of
doing it more
houses are good
uh because then i can podcast whenever i
want i don't have to be parked in a
specific location
but houses are bad because they make you
work for it
they are time sinks and if you want to
live in a house you're going to spend
most of your time not in a house you're
going to spend most of your time working
to make sure you can live in a house
so you have never lived in korea then
i lived in korea for
a month
so
is it a contest
i think a lot of people when they meet
a foreigner they don't want them to have
lived anywhere else
they don't want there to be another side
to them
they want to be like oh this side that
i'm seeing is all there is i don't have
to get to know another side of you
otherwise i'd be too complicated and i
would have to think of you in a way
that's different than everyone else that
i think of
um but
i mean i do have a very deep asian side
that most people
never get to see
because uh
i don't speak korean to people who don't
understand it but also i hope that my
asian side comes out in my western side
and that it all combines into one great
asian american
jasmine is not a woman jasmine you
[ __ ]
gender-baiting [ __ ] of a [ __ ]
[Music]
i can say [ __ ]
um but yeah i mean obviously it's a dude
um
dudes are
equipped for van life
they have
not as many holes that
need protecting they have two or three
holes i'm not hi zeke 89. that's going
to be my new intro for this podcast is
i'm not high i'm not tired my eyes are
open this is my podcast
please stop asking i'm not high
i wish i was high but it uh [ __ ] up my
throat so i've been taking some time off
i just had american chinese food for
dinner like a christmas story
are you jewish chris young
um
oh someone doesn't like my wokeness
completely unbearable i mean
do you want to just be an animal and
just be primitive and
just enjoy the uh
conserving the society that you live in
or do you want to make something better
i would love the van like stevo and tom
green
then i could have a studio in my van
which i kind of do already i mean i have
this thing in my laptop and all that
i call the dynavap as badass oh no do
you own any
guns
no i really want a gun but it's really
hard to get a gun in texas if you don't
have a texas license
so i'm thinking of getting a texas
license just so i can get him i'm
[ __ ]
pp walter k 44 92
or whatever
te has
uh what's your personal pronoun my
personal pronoun is chincaroni and
[ __ ]
um
william has a great joke about that
which i don't think has come out yet
yeah but i thought like it's texas i
should be able to get a gun but
apparently i have to be a resident here
i can't just buy a gun here
if comedy doesn't work it would you
consider a career in software
engineering considering that i have no
experience in that field in order to
start from scratch
i would probably
uh
not
do software engineering
i would try probably try to build
something artistic or
i don't know do something
podcast related
um
when is swiggy coming back to kill tony
he hasn't been pulled up yet so i don't
know hopefully he gets pulled up soon
so uh
it is a laughing skull shirt i'm wearing
go korean island by
it's called jeju island
laughing skull comedy festival 2018
back in the day
go korean island
um so yeah i love my van i love
everything about it i love all the
things that come with it
um i love the freedom i love the sex i
love the
other things
um
i think that it's great that
we live in a society
and i think that the bigger the society
the better
and the more
stuff in it the better
that it'll be
um
still no van tour
all righty no still no van tour with a
knoww is that you doing text-to-speech
yeah i mean i should do one really quick
and easy
um
i think the island boy phenomenon is
just a complete
uh surrender of the logical mind
to go deep into our subconscious and our
feelings
um
and just sort of hey
i'm
here i am just feeling i'm not thinking
at all because thinking is too hard and
it doesn't do anything
we have a society that just feels and
doesn't think and then we don't do
anything
because feeling is not a good foundation
for doing
i do do yoga
and i don't think that
it was meant as a compliment
oh my god
i need to
know the other way
fix my neck okay that looks a little
even
um
i just think that we shouldn't just
delve into our subconscious and because
if we do it looks ugly and weird and
it's not good enough it's shallow and
boring we need to think and those people
don't think they just feel hey man
that's kind of harsh in my mellow dude
why do you gotta be like that why you
gotta like say things that are like
weird like why can't you just say things
that are good and then we can all feel
good all the time even though our
economic material conditions are not
improving
we just gotta change how we feel and
then we won't have to do any revolution
lazy
uh
maybe revolution is necessary and maybe
we should do it there's kind of the
underdog now though i
reckon they are right there it's not
hurting anyone they're focusing people
to ask hardcore so then their values
yeah by doing nothing like i could do
that i could just like lay on the ground
and that would force people to think
about their values and who they are as a
person
have you thought about disgusting doing
a weekly podcast with a co-host if so
who i love doing it by myself and you
guys are the co-host the people the
power of the people
um
what kind of revolution
hopefully a dance dance kind of
revolution
uh hopefully a bloodless violence
revolution like the one that happened in
89
90.
you'd sub to my only fans that's cool
uh harness the power of meth start a
revolution i think meth is
uh
it's fine if you want to do it
i'm not in a van because i had this guy
give me a house for free for a week so i
said yes actually it wasn't free he paid
me to live here so this is my job is to
live in a house
and if you don't respect me
for working hard for the capitalist
economy then you're not a good american
i'm doing this for america i'm living in
this house
because
it is my responsibility
i must live in a house
so that we can function as an economy
and you can get your pizza hut delivered
on time
um
i love
the island boys
i love the island girls i love the
island transgenders
and i love everybody
except for
the goddamn conservatives
who are slowly
turning
the tacos into something that is an
abomination upon this earth
i do have a 16k bank account right now
i i spent a lot
um
i do think an economic crash is
inevitable uh that's what tim dillon
said on the joe rogan podcast
i think that eventually
we are going to run out of [ __ ]
uh because we're just making [ __ ] for no
reason and it's just empty and whatever
uh
conservatism
hey man i'm joking what you can't even
take a joke what are you a snowflake a
liberal
man i thought conservatives were cool
but they can't even take a joke it's
like they're conservative snowflakes or
something
uh that's the thing is if you're all
about the joke then you just gotta take
the joke all the time everything's a
jokes nothing serious you can't say
anything serious
um yeah it's just a hilarious hilarious
joke
we are about to have trench warfare with
russia
more like nuclear warfare with russia
trenches what's a trench gonna do
against a nuke how deep of a trench do
you need a dig you gotta have like a
[ __ ] 17 story trench
to survive a nuke probably not even that
um
so 16k is good i love having 16k i think
it's good to have that
uh uh send the tacos to russia to pacify
them
yeah
um
all the way from east africa holy [ __ ] i
don't even know what's over there how
would global nuclear warfare affect
global warming
nuclear warfare would deflect global
warming like this
when lana said we're all gonna die this
winter man
hey man
we're all gonna die this winter
oh
hey man i'm all gonna die this winter
we're all gonna die this winter
um i think that uh
i think the gun is just nice to have i
don't know if
it's the most useful thing to have
but it's nice to have
um just so that uh i don't have to die
uh i can fight back
hey guys i'm biden
and suicide rate and how do you feel
about it why is south korea overtaken
japan and suicide rate
and how do you feel about it i feel like
this about it
oh well
what are you gonna do
i think uh south korea and japan are
currently
uh under a model of
like work
is
going to set you free
and it's unhealthy and it's just like
it's not a very deep meaningful
connection to your life
and we don't have a very good useful
role for people other than
industrial
cattle they're just crop and people
don't like that and they see
that they're not that worthy for the
things that they actually value in
themselves which is their emotions and
feelings and
uh creativity and imagination
and so
they're like well if i don't matter to
these people then they won't matter when
i'm gone and then they kill themselves
and then uh
it's sad because
people that actually do love them are
like [ __ ]
they killed themselves i really was
relying on them to not [ __ ] do that
and then they get all sad then they kill
themselves it's like a thing
it happens over and over again um
so yeah i mean i think it's uh we need
to have a more
nuanced complex
idea of what a human is and then that
will manifest into how we treat people
as not just economic cattle and it's not
just button pushing
manual labors but an actual important
emotional beautiful being and then
people will feel more valued
and then they will uh contribute more to
the economy with their creativity
and their um
inventions and
things that they contribute like
music or songs or other things
so yeah i mean we need to stop looking
at people as [ __ ] whatever it's
button pushing
pencil pushing paper submitting people
and we need to start looking at people
differently and for that to happen we
need to not be so focused on money
the economy should work for us we
shouldn't work for the economy the whole
purpose of the economy is to make our
lives better and if the economy is to
serving that purpose what is the point
of that why are we sacrificing lives for
the economy the economy is just
an abstract concept we are what matters
and we are what changes the world we are
the most sentient uh
beings in the universe that we know of
and we should take care of ourselves
um
what do you think about the concept of
lying flat have you ever heard of the
concept of lying flat this thing in
china where they're just like not trying
to do anything they're just or japan
where they're just trying to be like
whatever
how tight is the least tony keeps on
regulars is he going to punish you for
calling joe rogan the little man
um i don't know why i called joe rogan
the little man i think i was just like
riffing i don't mean to call him the
little man but i did call him the big
man a bunch of times i think lying flat
is good but also not good because
you shouldn't contribute to an economy
that's not that useful and isn't really
doing anything but you also shouldn't do
nothing with your life
um instead of doing negative harm i
guess it's good to do nothing but
ideally you want to do positiveness
so i would just say
find something that you enjoy doing and
do it no matter how useless you think it
is because it's better than
harming the environment and destroying
rainforests which a lot of people take a
lot of value from
so as long as you're not
uh harming the world like it's an it's a
positive even if all you're doing is
making little key
chains um
uh at least you're doing something
positive so just
have some perspective and be like i
might not be doing much but at least i'm
not harming the world and that makes me
better than 99 of people or whatever
um
just found me i'm asian and trying to
stand up trying stand-up advice
um i would say as an asian doing
stand-up
just
quit
because
i've already got it covered bro no need
to have more than one asian in the game
the most important thing about an asian
doing stand-up is to have deference and
respect for me your elder and stand up
and to also
never succeed
so that i am the only one and i have
market domination and job security
uh as an asian doing stand-up comedy i
would say that
your role is to pave the way for me
as an asian new stand-up comedy i think
that
you could do hacky asian jokes i love
doing those i kind of got that market
cornered so
um
i uh i think asians doing stand-up
comedy just try to be honest say the
most vulnerable
embarrassing thing you can think of
because it's going to come out anyways
you might as well practice
having that out there
and
i would say that as a stand-up do a lot
of sets and just go out there and don't
take bombs personally
uh
don't take bombs personally uh it's just
practice
learn and improve and be ready to change
things about yourself that you weren't
ready to and also preserve the things
that need to be preserved and it's just
an art form and
you are great and just express yourself
and get better every day and then
eventually
you'll be skilled and proficient in the
art and that won't feel good
um
and uh you know don't take bombs
personally but also don't be so aloof
and detached from your sets that you
don't learn anything from it
how many sets before you get even kind
of good
well some people can be funny and really
good right away and then they
it's all about percentage like sometimes
uh you're the best person at the show
sometimes you're not and it's like how
many times are you the best person on
the show how many times are you funny
how many times are you good and it's all
about upping that percentage and getting
better and better and
uh it's also like
getting higher uh
kill rates of times you do well on stage
and also how how high you can fly like
how hard you can kill that also
increases so it really depends on the
person some people are very consistently
average
and some people are inconsistently
amazing high high low lows
um
and i think that um you know like
it depends on your style and you know
you should be trying for everything you
should be so whatever
i hope everything worked out i don't
know what happened
uh
should we invade north korea
as a dream i wish that we could record i
wish we could invade north korea because
they are whatever
and we i wish we could liberate it but
you know it's like the people gotta want
it and it's also like i don't know
whatever something's gonna happen over
there i wish that we could reunite with
north korea
it is a scar on the subconscious
psyche of all koreans is that we're
divided and we're only half as powerful
as we could be
we should be united and uh division is
not something that we should get used to
or be satisfied with we should fight for
the unification of korea
uh because korea would be great
um
[Music]
i uh
korea is divided because of usa mostly
um
i don't know
how i feel about that
i mean on the one hand korea was used as
a [ __ ]
you know
uh proxy war for russia and china or
russia and america so i'm not really
thrilled about that but then it's like
if russia didn't support
kim yunasong
and if america didn't support
or whatever the general whatever
the series of generals that we had
uh then it wouldn't have been so crazy
um so i don't know it's it's good that
south korea exists because it's doing
well and
it's not under north korea but you know
maybe if we were under north korea we
would have been able to sway the ship
and make it awesome
but uh you know
i don't know it's not a good thing that
foreign powers decided to split korea in
half to fight their cold war against
each other
it's not something that should have
happened and i hope one day that korea
is totally completely free of all
outside influences
meddling around
um and i uh resent the uh years of
dictatorship
that korea had to go through to gain
what it has now and uh
the blood of the martyrs of korea
have
watered the soil
and created a very powerful country that
is a
very
protest uh skilled and you know i think
i support
the student protesters of yonder years
or whatever
for the past weeks i've been just
chilling
maxing out
and just really sleeping a lot i've been
doing a lot of comedy
i've been resting and all that
um
because they decided which form of
government they wanted
the country to split because they
decided
which form of government they wanted i
think the country split because america
and russia went in there and was like no
no we're gonna have this part you guys
have that part
i don't think it was a choice by the
koreans
uh which is sad but you know maybe next
time
korean to japanese i mean korea was
getting [ __ ] by japan and it was very
unpleasant
um
hanging out in the marble mansion
this is such a nice house and i love it
and thank you to the guy who owns it for
letting me stay here
oh [ __ ]
um it's hard to be symmetrical because
it's all like [ __ ] weird it's like my
left hand
whatever
do i believe in magic mushrooms i mean i
believe they exist i've consumed
multiple
uh capsules of them
and stems of them multiple times so i'm
sure that they exist and they've changed
my brain indelibly so yes i'm sure that
they exist i think they're a wonderful
tool and i would love to use this tool
again in a very short amount of time
um
[Music]
because some koreans
and power hungry that's why
um i mean able fable i don't know how
much you know about korea i don't know
that much so i'm just gonna let the
experts handle korea and i'll just
handle these big guns
um i love mushrooms i think they're
great it's hard to talk about them like
what like what do i say about them
they're great i love doing them they
make me feel different they make me look
at the world different
[Music]
mushrooms are great
south korea has become seems to have
become an outsider's economic power that
might not have happened without such
strong allies invested in the proxy war
they also established a dictator who he
ruled with an iron fist and squashed any
descent and south korea only became
more rich than north korea in the 70s
and 80s
so
a lot of a lot of bad [ __ ] happened in
korea
and it's a place with a lot of uh
i would say trauma being split in half
families divided
and all that i kind of have a six pack
but i don't like showing it off because
i i have to show off my skinny little
waist to show off my six pack
um
what's your favorite kill tony memory
probably kissing stormy because i really
love stormy which city have you enjoyed
living in the most and why probably
austin [ __ ] texas because i met
joe rogan and opened up for him and then
became a kill tony regular and ate a lot
of good barbecue and drink for free
and just had a really really great time
overall in austin texas so yeah i
[ __ ] love austin the city has been
the best to me i bet i was in new york
three years grinding my ass off in the
subway and the [ __ ] dirty streets
living on in a van
right on [ __ ] 21st street
and what do i have to show for it those
people didn't didn't respect me they
didn't like me they're all
compromised all they do is kiss each
other's asses and try to get on shows
[ __ ] you
i come to austin in six months i'm
already opening up for joe rogan
[ __ ] new york all the old entrenched
powers are [ __ ]
they just want people who will make them
feel good whether it's they're hot and
they want to hang around them or they
like to
be like oh i'm the one that discovered
this guy or is like some douchebag that
you like wish that you look like so you
book him
[ __ ] new york new york is not a good
place for comedy because they squish
talent they make you work hard for no
reason
and they
never reward you and it's not a
meritocracy
[ __ ] new york la was a little nicer to
me but i was only there two or three
months so i didn't really get a feel for
that place or how they would receive me
and i think that a lot of that is the
same over there but i think la's a
little better than new york new york is
all about favoritism and kissing ass and
i really grew to resent that place but
it was an amazing place and i loved it
and i loved being in that scene
amazing comedian some of the funniest
all were attracted there and if we can
do that in new york if all those people
are attracted to new york then we can
just do that little thing in austin and
just be like new place
a new rendezvous
receiver play aqui por favor
austin not [ __ ] new york where people
have already established the
infrastructure and don't want to change
their [ __ ]
i would rather hang out with people who
have a new infrastructure set up and
aren't just like old bitter comics who
have
worked years to be able to book people
and then they use that power to get
drugs or sex or anything else besides
getting funnier
okay
for christmas all i want is for hans to
open his eyes
merry [ __ ] christmas
it's the holidays time
and my eyes are open to the horrors of
our economy
if you love mushrooms hans invest in
bwvi
i'm not gonna invest in stuff
what's your favorite mo comedian at the
moment
my favorite comedian at the moment is
probably
god damn it
i don't know that's a tough one
i haven't been listening to a lot of
comedy recently it's hard to put myself
in that situation because i'm like oh
this guy's talking to an audience and
he's talking to them like this oh [ __ ]
what would i do in that situation i
would probably go like this and it's
just a lot of mental stress and instead
i would rather watch starcraft 2
watching two korean stallions battle
intellectually to find out who has a
higher apm and the most strategic
tactical mind
so i haven't been listening to a lot of
comedy recently i love mark normand i
love good joke writers i love joe rogan
he's always been my favorite i'm not
just saying that
i've always loved the big man
a big man on campus
why does my neck not look straight
how do i get this
anyways
um what is the next six straight blues
uh i'll try to do it it's just such a
pain in the ass i have to open myself up
to these animals
and then edit it and then watch me open
myself up to animals and it's just a lot
of a lot of work
um
watching people do stand-up comedy is
like watching someone have sex with your
girlfriend
you're like oh look at this guy having
sex with her in that position i should
try that position
oh look he's like doing that thing
i should try doing that thing
oh look i never make the audience sound
like that
how come he can make the audience sound
like that but i can't i must have a tiny
little comedy skill
[ __ ]
i must have a tiny comedy [ __ ]
i need to go more towards that
now
i want to watch the louis ck special but
i have to watch it for free
um
sorry i was trying to fix my neck
it's hard because this is like all
reversed and [ __ ]
is that scoliosis i'm a chiropractor
[Laughter]
oh yeah trying to fix my [ __ ]
why the long face i've always got a long
face because i got a big old jaw
um
how did your pirate louis special as a
streaming i don't want to torrent it but
i'll torrent it on my phone i just don't
want to get caught doing [ __ ]
what's your sc2 apm probably like 120
right now
i played a couple games and it's fun
it's devastating when you lose
but um
it's pretty fun when you win it's just
so weird because someone has to lose
for
someone else it's a zero-sum game one
person gets all the emotional uh
awesomeness and the other person gets
none of it so it's just difficult
difficult to do because you know
someone's feeling shitty or maybe you're
the one that's feeling shitty so it's
just weird
um
it's starcraft 2 is like different too
because it's like you're stupid if you
lose the other person beat you mentally
so you're delving deep into people's
heads and stuff so
it's not just like losing a game of i
spy it's like you're dumb
that you're dumber than this guy so it's
just hard to play
uh without getting your feelings hurt
and that's when i get mad and i go like
this
oh i wanna know when and i didn't and i
feel bad
uh what's your favorite orifice probably
the vagina
i love it
the [ __ ] it's like really tight
around the ring
and then once you go in there it's like
the halls of mariah
maria
is like
so empty and cavernous but the vagina is
like
[Music]
uh so yeah sorry to be boring maybe the
nostril's a good
orifice f10n as fast as you can and
forget yeah just play another game and
leave on a high note
how's the serenade going with christina
mariani
christina mariani uh we were going to
play catan but it never happened so i'll
just have to keep at it i have to keep
inviting her
it's just weird right now because the
coronavirus cases are off the charts
it's bonkers out here
it's uh that time of year
you know
where
we gotta
be careful and [ __ ]
look at that [ __ ]
so right now i'm trying to quarantine i
did a quarantine here
july
june
may
right around here whoop
and then right here
i was quarantining up to here
and then i came back to society
here i was in l.a here i was in the
desert
here i was in society and now we're here
so i'm i'm trying not to meet people i
talk to them that's why this streaming
thing is awesome
i might go do a podcast later with gary
faust and gina hyena
but that's remains to be seen
uh yeah this that wasn't a crypto chart
that was a coronavirus chart and
that's what i'm invested in while you
guys are investing in
crypto i'm investing in coronavirus and
let's just say the numbers keep going up
it's a it's a bull market
bear market
on bull market
i wish i could invest in coronavirus
it's a sure fire strategy
so i uh
really enjoyed uh
the holidays
um my favorite part was yesterday i went
over to gary faust's house for the faust
house
and got a tour got to hold some of his
guns
uh
held his uh
ar-15 the classic american ar-15
and um
held his revolver
held uh eli halpern's
glock or whatever
you could invest in vaccine companies or
short airlines
no i want to directly help out
coronavirus
i want to go
give coronavirus money and be like
here's some money use it to find a nice
air-conditioned room and just float
around in it
uh this is not my van this is my
buddy's home that i'm staying in
uh
who would win in a fight tony a red band
so tony already said on a podcast called
the joe rogan podcast that he defeated
david lucas in a wrestling match
so i would have to say that tony
hinchcliffe has an advantage in terms
of skill and red band has an advantage
in terms of
size
and weight
so i would say that i would like to bet
on tony because i'm a fan of skill over
size just as a small man myself
but you can never underestimate
the panicky
furtive movements of a fat man under
pressure
so i would say it's like
pretty pretty 50 50.
you know because tony has that mentality
of like i deserve to win
but red band has that
uh
desire for pleasure and comfort that he
knows will come from defeating his
opponent and getting to eat more
uh
wonderful korean food from his lovely
girlfriend
uh
have you tried a flotation tank no i
don't think i have i think i had a dream
about trying a floatation tank but i
don't think it actually ever happened
so it's just interesting
uh yeah i mean i feel like i have
i act like i have but i haven't actually
done it
yeah and red band has been watching [ __ ]
for a long time but honestly so is tony
so that's a it's a wash
so um
why did you originally move to austin
um i was staying in yuma arizona with my
friend rebecca and she was like
well
i don't know where you should go after
this because i stayed with her for like
a month and then i was like what is the
next step in my life i had to move on
and then um
and then i was like where do i go and
then she was like well austin's a really
cool city you should go there
uh if i were you i'd go to austin that's
what she suggested for me and then i
took that seriously and i was also like
i already know la i've been to la i know
what that's going to be like it's going
to be like whatever
and i've never been to austin i mean i
have been but i haven't like done comedy
in austin for a long period of time
that's going to be a new adventure and
plus joe rogan's there
tony hinchcliffe killed tony's there
redbin is there so it was like well i i
know la and i know what that's going to
be like which is fine it's just open
mics and just cool people and you know i
already know everyone there or everyone
i'm gonna know there
um
[Music]
but austin what seemed like a cool new
adventure something that i haven't tried
before
and also i was like well if i don't like
it i live in a van i can just leave
and uh so i was like let's give it a
shot you know that's that was a
mentality it's like this is a new thing
i want to try it out i don't want to say
that i wasn't there for austin when it's
heyday when it was like awesome so this
is a new experience is cool so i wanted
to give it a shot
and i know that everyone thinks they're
gonna move to austin and become a
regular on kill tony and start opening
up for joe rogan but that's just not how
it works
it's just not
it's not gonna happen
for you or me or anyone
but yeah i mean i i'd say it paid off it
was like a dream come true i couldn't i
i was like when i was moving here i was
like man
i i i really gotta temper my
expectations because i don't want to
just like be sad that i'm not gonna get
to meet joe rogan when it's been like
seven months and i still haven't even
got to suckle on his teats
but then uh then it all happened so
what are you gonna do
um
it was a pretty cool experience for me
to come here and just have all my
wildest dreams come true the only thing
that i wish would happen now is that i
would become a legit headliner and be
really good at comedy so that's still in
the works i'm still working on that that
hasn't magically changed
so that's just weird
um
so yeah that's what i moved here for and
now i'm staying here because it's been
amazing to me and now i'm gonna [ __ ]
stay here forever
uh
do you think if you weren't working for
tony if you had still be opening for joe
definitely not
definitely not
unless i did it some other way but this
was like the quickest best way to get it
and i'm thankful that peng dang was such
an asian [ __ ] that he opened the
door for me
uh yes i'm gonna do the van tour soon
would you hire writers depends
depends man i kind of want to say what i
want to say i mean i have plenty of
stuff i want to say if they can make
that better i'm sure i would take that
advice but i don't know it just seems
like i have to kind of do it on my own
or else it's not the same
what do you think about the racism
towards white people
um i mean i think if we're going to
create a new society we don't want to do
it on a foundation of racism so it's
like imperative that we started out the
right way by not being racist to white
people
i do think that white people have
committed the most crimes against
humanity the most recently and got
punished the least for it
so i think that there's a lot of
resentment built up and a lot of
arrogance amongst white people that uh
white is right and they didn't do
anything wrong but i mean
there's a lot that was done wrong that
needs to be uh accounted for and all
that but i don't think that uh
yelling at white people is gonna solve
anything i think that uh
that white people um you know
maybe they need to get roasted a little
bit
yeah i'm generalizing white people
um i mean i just think that a lot of
people are resentful towards white
people because of the things that have
happened um
i think that uh
the racism against white people
shouldn't be done and uh we should
account for the crimes of the past in a
more
um
equinomous magnanimous way
um and i think that there's a lot of
white people who refuse to change
the horrible things that are happening
right now
and i think that's not all right i think
that uh there should be like a lot of
stuff that changes
there are many heinous acts committed to
the east from western civilization true
wild history there's also a lot of [ __ ]
that the japanese did
where they raped and pillaged
and [ __ ]
did all that [ __ ] to china and korea and
the philippines uh mongols genghis khan
was pretty bad
well whatever you know like uh japanese
people
they were pretty humiliated after world
war ii i think they learned their lesson
uh europeans learned their lesson
they're like holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] was
that let's not do that again but i think
americans
there was a sort of removed for them
they didn't really uh
they didn't really uh
were like oh [ __ ] we should uh not
do wars and exploit people and all that
i think that
they uh they they were like they did
whatever
they they uh
they didn't uh fixed fix this [ __ ]
after world war ii
but um
yeah i just think that white people have
done the most
uh because there was just more people
around later
and they did it more recently and got
punished at least for it so i think
that's
uh
left a mark on white culture that
is unseemly
and
you know not that good
uh but i think that
we
need to help white people
fix their [ __ ]
if they'll accept us or if they even
think they need to um
all right people suffering from success
yeah i mean uh
they all have anxiety and mental illness
illness
do you want to have children someday yes
you haven't witnessed racism until
you've hung out on an indian reservation
lol
over those little eyes
i got aids so i mean i don't know i
think that uh racism against white
people is ugly and gross and i think
that we shouldn't do it
i think that uh white people are in
power right now so there's gonna be a
lot of sniping like if you're in power
like
don't expect to like just have it easy
there's people are gonna like
talk [ __ ] about you like it's gonna
happen
and with great power comes great
responsibility and white people have to
uh
figure out how they're gonna use that
and use it for good instead of evil
i don't know if voting for trump is a
sign that white people in america have
are really uh
sorry and that they're gonna fix their
ways i think they're that's a sign that
they might double down
uh so i don't think that's a good sign
but uh i mean
i don't hate white people i love white
people
uh it's just like
i think that there's
a lot of
bad things that are happening
in uh
white culture
but also a lot of good things happening
at the same time i mean marijuana
legalization and gay marriage they're
the future they have free speech they
have individual rights and that's
something that uh should be the future
and that they carry the torch for that
but they also have a lot of imperialism
and colonialism in their culture
anyways why people
what is it i think like individual white
people are awesome i think that uh
yeah i don't know
white people someone someone did that
someone made me answer that question
when did you get your first big laugh i
don't know
i always thought i was funny
which is probably not true i was
probably delusional from the beginning
um
uh
trump is so awesome and brave i
definitely prefer the new band
white people what's your favorite pizza
i think the treatment was more
representative broken establishment of
populism i think that's why bernie
was
also at the same time as republican
primary just granted
i mean i don't want to let trump
supporters off the hook i don't think
that was a very sane or kind thing to do
to people
um i think in everything that magara
actually made a lot of people on the
right become less racist i definitely
don't think that's the case
i think that'd be nice to think i think
it's more wishful thinking
and i've been cheering you on since you
started on kt thank you white man
you are now not racist i bless you with
non-racism because i'm a minority even
though i'm basically white
do you think trans women are women i
wish i was white so i could hate white
people like how i want to hate white
people it's not like i hate white people
as an other i think that the uh
the whiteness is in me and i hate that
part of myself or something like that
has your family been supportive on your
decision to pursue comedy yes
when is the next podcast with riley and
the boys probably when the next [ __ ]
whatever
uh
[Music]
uh probably when the next uh pandemic
lull comes into place the next trough in
the graph
uh
i play a lot of fortnite
uh how much planning goes into each week
on kill tony
i write i write i write i write every
day uh i practice my bits i used to
practice my bet at open mics i practice
my bits
and then i
on the day of
i think about what i want to say
and then i picked the best thing to say
the day of i uh
it's just a general sort of anxiety that
comes from kill tony that's like oh i
have to have a good set oh come on don't
be a loser don't bow do really good
you got internalized whiteness i'm out
of jeremiah williams hans podcast
jeremiah watkins william montgomery hans
kim podcast i would love that
i don't really know jeremiah but william
and i have been talking are you like
skinny no in fact they are the fattest
part of my skinny little body i have big
old korean thighs and calves
it's nice for a man but as a woman i
think it'd be difficult
uh yeah i can't do open mics anymore
um
give us an asian impression oh very very
very very nice i'm asian oh so asian are
you coming to chicken thai express i
love chicken and i love asia
oh i'm so asian and so weak and so tiny
and nobody respects me ho ho-ho but it's
okay because i'm a little cockroachy
um
who killed jfk probably the powers the
existing infrastructure i always say
that the
probably the the people that
uh wanted to
constant war and [ __ ]
um
do a white person impression please i
already did that
hi guys i'm here for the barbecue do you
guys have kebabs ready i would love to
try your chips
oh my god these are delectable
i can't believe you've been keeping this
from me maria
whoa
i think i felt a little boner popping up
i don't have a red banner tony
impression where do you see your comedy
career headed or it becoming is becoming
a headline
a headline the ceiling for you
uh yeah being a headliner is a ceiling
for me but luckily it's a very very high
ceiling i mean joe rogan is a headliner
he does stadiums and arenas and uh yeah
that's a very high ceiling that's a
ceiling that not everyone gets to reach
and i hope one day to reach that ceiling
to be able to have an audience of
millions of people and thousands tens of
thousands come out to see me in person
in every city i travel to
wow
amazing who wouldn't want that i want
that
hans gay
oh okay i'm gay i'm gay because
everything that uh is out there needs to
be brought down with gayness
um can you do an impression where are
your telegrams it's funny you should ask
they're always within reach they've
actually been gone off the shelves of
heb and walmart for a while
and they've just come back i think it's
because of the strike i hope that they
got what they wanted the strikers i
support the striking workers i think
that we need to get workers rights to be
awesome
and i think in america with uh workers
rights is awesome
uh how much can you deadlift i've only
been deadlifting 135 because i'm not
really trying to max out i'm just trying
to work out you know get my muscles
moving and going and i don't want to
injure myself that's my number one
concern every time i work out i'm trying
not to injure myself so i haven't been
deadlifting a lot but i bet my max right
now is probably like once 200 or
something it's not a lot i'm a very weak
little boy but luckily i make up for it
with my
sexual
stamina my body mass index is pretty low
you could be joe coy if you hook up with
chelsea handler do you still get nervous
on stage all the time
probably not as nervous as they did in
the beginning
what
it's a sign of too much psychedelics
when you have a hard time engaging in
reality when you're
not be able to function in society
um but honestly i don't really value
functioning in society
uh have you tried to sign up for agt
yeah i actually
did an audition for them i got called
back once but didn't get the second call
back
uh having a god mentality is a sign of
too many psychedelics yeah i mean it's
manifests itself in very different ways
depends on who you are as a person and
uh
what a lot of different things um
asian's got talent
got talent espana
it's the next podcast with riley and the
boys i don't know really depends on them
and me
i love portland oregon it's a city that
stood up for itself and i respect that
are you still doing a white boy
impression or is that over yeah i mean
i'm doing a white person impression all
the time my life is lived as a white man
how would you change this live chat
setup if you could
uh the setup
i don't know i would like to
simultaneously stream on twitch and
youtube and instagram i would just like
to put it all out there because honestly
the skin doesn't matter what matters is
the people and talking to them
um
what i would change is that
i would have like a list of questions
and whenever i ran out of things to talk
about i could just look at the list
uh and then like there'd be upvotes or
people who like have the best questions
would be voted to the top
oh
hi mari oh
i'm racist and i uh say the shocking
things all the time
uh
you can do that i'm pretty sure it's
called simulcast
i think it's like recast or something
um
asians
what do asians think about me i really
don't know i haven't really heard a lot
i've heard from individual asians every
now and then the smattering of asians
but i think asians as a monolith are
[Music]
they're very like
all together they either love you or
hate you so i haven't you know like it's
bipolar like right now they haven't
really picked up on me which i'm happy
for uh i don't really
need them right now i'm sure i will in
the future when i'm touring and i want
them to come out i think it'd be great
to have them out
but i honestly
don't think that their culture is very
rich or nuanced and i'm
i don't know how they'll take me so i
don't really make any forays into that
that audience i think that asians are
very difficult some of them are like
woke liberals
who can't take a joke
but who i agree with politically
and then others are just like all asian
and like
they they're not
uh
i don't know they're they're not a part
of western culture in a significant way
um asian americans i think are uh
very neurotic and sort of jewishy
they're like hmm
i don't know that joke seems problematic
so uh
i uh i don't need that uh voice in my
life uh
i think that
rather than
censor and curtail every little
individual thought and emotion that you
have it's better to get it all out there
and find out where the root of that
problem is coming
from uh
yeah
i'm not a trans woman
um
i am asian you're hippons
um
what's black israelite say about asians
i think black israelites have uh
kind of forgotten about us
andrew wong thank you for the australian
money
um i'm sorry if i offended anything
i said about asians offended you but uh
you know i love asians it's just
i don't know they're very insular they
don't really express themselves and
that's not a very good comedy audience
but uh yeah i mean i love asians and i
think that we're powerful and awesome
and uh i just haven't really talked to
them that much
so i guess i have the white person's
impression of asians but i think that
asians can be great and i think that i'm
excited to perform for asians because
i'm sure that like a lot of things that
i do
that i thought were weird are like
actually just asian things and that
they'll understand me in a deeper way
than other audiences can so
i really um
i really respect asian [ __ ] or whatever
um
so yeah i'm probably gonna eat right now
and have a good time so thank you for
tuning in and i hope that we can uh all
you know catch up and hang out and do
stuff going to dallas i'm going to
houston so if you're in those cities
please come out to the stand-up shows
why do you think there are different
races of people because we all grew up
in different areas of the globe and we
were adopted
to survive in that different climate or
whatever
what are your classes on the difference
between people raised in cold climates
resolutions to see i don't know texas
um yeah i mean it's different i think
culturally we're all the same because we
all got the same youtube and all that
uh he's meeting kim jong-un
uh i don't really want to meet kim
jong-un i um
i don't know how much i can learn from
him i mean it'd be cool to learn how to
like do a country run a country
uh but thank you guys and uh if you're
in houston or if you're in dallas please
come out if you're in austin please come
out to other people
on sunday six at creek in the cave
uh
yeah i'll uh
post a link tree
to all my tour dates and everything
thank you
love you